merci de nous retrouver en direct sur
figaro live et fille sur youtube sur
notre chaîne figaro live le 16 octobre
2020 samuel pâtit était assassiné à
proximité du collège dans lequel il
enseignait à conflans-sainte-honorine
dans les yvelines un an après la france
rend hommage à ce professeur d'histoire
géo de 47 ans décapité par un terroriste
islamiste pour avoir montré des
caricatures de mahomet à ses élèves afin
d'évoquer la laïcité aujourd'hui veille
du premier anniversaire du drame un
hommage est organisée dans les
établissements scolaires les écoles et
les établissements pourront notamment
organiser une minute de silence en
mémoire de samuel patty est consacré une
heure de cours à un temps dommage et des
changes nous devrions pouvoir vous faire
vivre en direct à midi tout à l'heure la
minute de silence organisé par le lycée
jean de la fontaine dans le 16e
arrondissement de paris en présence du
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer de cérémonies sont
prévues au collège du bois donne à
conflans sainte honorine ou enseigner ça
mais elle pâtit la première entre
enseignants et élèves doit se dérouler
en fin d'après midi aujourd'hui
la seconde aura lieu demain samedi avec
les professeurs les élèves mais aussi
quelques parents d'élèves et des
officiels dont jean michel blanquer
demain toujours un moment de
recueillement sera orchestrée par la
ville dans laquelle habite et le
professeur à eragny sur oise dans le val
d'oise et enfin un hommage plus
institutionnels se déroulera également
demain matin au ministère de l'éducation
nationale où une plaque sera dévoilée
avant une rencontre des proches et de la
famille de samuel pâtit avec le chef de
l'état emmanuel macron et le premier
ministre jean castex et je précise
également qu'en parallèle de toutes ces
commémorations et hommages un square ça
mais elle pâtit sera également inauguré
samedi demain donc en face de la
sorbonne lors d'une cérémonie que la
mairie de paris veut simple et
recueillie bonjour jean kikizo là
bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
ce matin pour parler de ça mais elle
pâtit en cette veille du premier
anniversaire de l'assassinât dont il a
été la victime de l'attentât dont il a
été la victime vous êtes rédacteur en
chef adjoint au figaro société
spécialiste de terrorisme quel respect
quelles réflexions vous inspirent quelle
réflexion doit nous inspirer
les hommages nombreux en mémoire de sa
belle pâtit alors
malheureusement depuis maintenant
six ans depuis depuis le début de cette
vague d'attentats terroristes qui naquit
n'a pas cessé depuis janvier 2015 il ya
eu beaucoup d'hommages celui ci est
naturellement très particulier d'abord
parce que il y a le l'horreur et le choc
la décapitation d'un professeur par
définition les terroristes essaient
toujours de franchir une étape dans
l'horreur ils égorgent appraître ils
massacrent des spectateurs d'un concert
il essaye de tuer des gens venus
assister à un match de football voilà à
chaque fois il ya naturellement la
décision
consciente de franchir un pas dans
l'horreur et de terroriser la population
l'a particulièrement la victime était
vraiment une victime
exceptionnel un professeur
d'histoire-géographie un collège de
banlieue parisienne et je pense que
voilà ça englobe l'ensemble de la
communauté nationale les professeurs
l'éducation nationale les parents
d'élèves doudou ledoux l'ampleur de ceux
de cet hommage alors là l'assassinât de
sa mère pattie avait suscité la
sidération et l'émotion dans la france
entière son visage nous est devenu
évidemment familier à travers deux
portraits qui sont parus rapidement dans
les jours qui ont suivi sa décapitation
et son meurtre j'aimerais qu'on revienne
quelques minutes sur l'homme qui était
samuel pâtit qui était samuel pâtit gens
quittent isola alors comme je les dis
donc il avait il venait juste d'avoir 47
ans au moment de son assassinat enfin
mois auparavant un professeur d'histoire
géographie
quelqu'un qui était décrit par
ses élèves dont j'ai rencontré certains
le soir même de l'assassinât
à conflans devant le collège qui était
décrite par certains comme un prof
un bon professeur
et quelqu'un qui en fait visiblement
d'après les témoignages qui sont apparus
depuis notamment le témoignage sa soeur
récemment dans le quotidien la croix
kiki véritablement avait une approche
très à la fois respectueuse et
précautionneuse puisque
son cours qui va amener
l'attentât il avait été visiblement
pensé réfléchi
il avait demandé à sa mère institutrice
il y avait eu une discussion familiale
il ya vraiment quelqu'un conscient de
son de son devoir d'enseignants
quelqu'un de courageux parce que faire
ce qu'il a fait en octobre 2020 après
donc encore une fois une vague
d'attentats ininterrompue
c'était quelque chose qui pouvait
entraîner un certain risque je pense
qu'il en était conscient
mais voilà c'est un bon prof visiblement
un prof qui a qui a marqué une bonne
partie de ses élèves il s'intéressait
aussi aux religions puisque je crois
qu'il avait étudié le coran également
en amont de ces cours et de sa carrière
quelques années auparavant c'est ce que
disait je crois sa soeur gaël dans la
croix donc il avait effectivement un
regard assez
ouvert et pédagogique on va dire sûr sûr
sûr sûr les événements dans leur
ensemble et puis sur sur ce qui faisait
naître chez certains la discorde et le
débat absolument oui effectivement je
pense que c'était vraiment encore une
fois quelqu'un qui était comme un bon
prof d'histoire-géo on en a tous connu
curieux curieux de l'histoire curieux du
monde curieux de ce qui se passait et
désireux de comprendre un peu les
événements de son temps j'aimerais qu'on
y revienne gentil zola alors qu'on voit
l'image de samuel pâti à l'image cette
photo bien connue de tout le monde
désormais que s'est il passé ce 16
octobre 2020 il ya bientôt un an jour
pour jour donc le jour de l'assassinât
de sa mère pattie vous y était vous
étiez ce jour là en fin de journée sur
place également oui je je je je me suis
rendu effectivement devant ce collège
bon ce qui s'est passé auparavant c'est
connu est malheureusement trop bien
connu un terroriste islamiste
abdullah khan zoroff âgé de 18 ans l'âge
à la limite ajoute encore plus à
l'horreur du fait je veux dire un jeune
homme totalement radicaliser qui qui
l'attend à la sortie qui le suit qui
l'eu le décapite
et ensuite et ensuite après cette
horreur donc cette attente devant le
collège dans le soir qui descend
en attendant les autorités le chef de
l'état et puis ces collégiens en fait
qu'on voit arriver
alerté par les réseaux sociaux qui vont
jouer un rôle qu'ils ont joué un rôle
dans cette tragédie également alerté par
les réseaux sociaux des collégiens qui
arrivent par petits groupes et qui
commence à discuter qui échangent avec
les nombreux journalistes qui sont
présents sur place et donc une ambiance
pour tout dire un peu un peu surréaliste
en fait de cet échange entre les
collégiens qui sont tout d'un coup
plongé dans une réalité totalement
atroce
et qui en même temps on l'a on
l'attitude de la rage c'est à dire un
mélange de deux
peut-être de légèreté ou d'inconscience
voilà
un événement qui vous a frappé plus
particulièrement dans vos échanges avec
ces jeunes collégiens alors justement
quand on quand on discute avec c'est
avec ces jeunes
il ya plusieurs choses en fait qui
frappe d'abord
il a serré fait d'abord il ya d'abord il
ya pour une partie d'entre eux cette
volonté de chahuter un petit peu devant
les quelques équipes de télévision
présentes bon là on est on est dans une
ambiance on est dans une ambiance
collégienne et en même temps à côté à
quelques centaines de mètres du corps
d'un professeur décapité il ya également
la réflexion de certains très jeunes
souvent sur oui effectivement
on en parlait au collège il avait
insulté le prophète et tout en rajoutant
tout de suite que naturellement ça ne
justifiait pas la mort et puis cette
scène totalement surréaliste d'une d'une
gamine haute comme trois pommes qui au
milieu de la conversation vous dit
soudain mais vous voulez le voir et il
vous faut il vous faut 5 secondes pour
comprendre de quoi elle parle et elle a
son portable comme nous tous et et elle
vous montre la photo de la tête
décapitée du professeur qui circule sur
les réseaux sociaux
je crois par le terroriste lui-même
absolument acte absolument dando et
voilà dont on a pensé dans un premier
temps que c'était un
fait qui est tellement elle était
tellement l'image était était
surréaliste et qui malheureusement était
là et elle à l'image de
2,7 tête et donc voilà c'est c'est un
moment totalement surréaliste est
vraiment une soirée totalement
surréaliste de télescopage entre hank
encore une fois entre l'univers du
terrorisme et l'univers d'un collège de
banlieue parisienne
qu'est ce qui a provoqué la haine et le
passage à l'acte du terroriste qui en
vient à décapiter un enseignant d'un
devant un collège dans une ville moyenne
de l'île de france on en arrive là
comment qu'est ce qui a suscité cette
haine chez cet individu alors
j'apporterai de réponse est là il faut
effectivement s'éloigner de ce soir
devant le collège de conflans sainte
honorine et prendre un tout petit peu de
distance
la haine d'abdul hack and the rough
c'est celle de mohamed merah en mars
2012 quand il met une balle dans la tête
d'une petite fille devant une école
juive à toulouse
cette haine c'est la haine du terrorisme
islamiste qui nous frappent
régulièrement depuis maintenant des
années j'aurais tendance à dire même des
décennies puisque les attentats de 1995
était également des attentats islamistes
ça c'est le contexte depuis janvier 2015
nous avons eu 39 attentat islamiste
dont 21 ont abouti 19 ont échoué 18
partants ont échoué mais ça fait quand
même 39 tentatives de tuer au nom du
terrorisme islamiste bon cette haine
elle est fondée donc sûr on va pas faire
à court / / donc le l'islamisme et le
djihadisme qui considère qu'il faut
frapper les mécréants et les mauvais
croyants
après il ya un contexte un peu plus
immédiat
abdullah khan the rough il est aussi
animé non seulement par cette haine qui
remonte à plusieurs décennies en arrière
mais également par un contexte qui
démarre au début de septembre 2020 avec
le procès des attentats de l'attentât
contre charlie hebdo
avec le fait que charlie hebdo publié
les caricatures de mahomet est
hélas si on parle caricatures du
prophète on revient encore en arrière
avec ce qui s'est passé au danemark dans
les années 2000 et ça permet de rappeler
que l'islamisme n'est pas un phénomène
qui concerne les légumes à la france
mettra phénomène mondial c'est toujours
important de le rappeler qu'il ya une
distance historique est également une
étendue géographique et donc à partir de
là la france en septembre 2020 est visé
par plusieurs groupes terroristes
l'ensemble des groupes terroristes
et par toute la mouvance jihadiste
avec l'idée de frapper ceux qui
insultent le prophète il faut se
rappeler qu'avant l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit il y as en septembre un terroriste
pakistanais qui attaquent deux personnes
qui se trouvent devant l'ancien siège de
charlie hebdo
il pensait que le journal il était
encore qui les blesse grièvement et donc
l'acte du terroriste and the rough il se
comprend dans cette succession de
menaces
de visant la france et après cet
attentat de septembre qui sera ensuite
suivie après l'assassinât de samuel pâti
comme on le sait par un troisième
attentat dans cet automne 2020 contre
des croyants à nice alors vous l'avez
cité hand the rough abdullah groff c'est
le nom de ce terroriste il avait 18 ans
était un individu d'origine russe
tchétchène qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
d'autre de cet individu de ce terroriste
qui a donc assassiné samuel pâtit alors
le premier point vous l'avez dit il est
issu de la communauté tchétchène il est
là il est
sa famille a obtenu le statut de réfugié
politique donc il l'a obtenue grâce à sa
famille il est issu d'une communauté qui
pose pas mal de problèmes aux services
de renseignement en ce qui concerne la
radicalisation
car une petite minorité et notamment
chez les jeunes
affichent une très grande radicalité qui
parfois d'ailleurs
pose des problèmes également
aux tchétchènes eux mêmes aux
responsables de la communauté eux mêmes
et qui sont souvent qualifiés par les
experts du terrorisme qu'on peut croiser
quand on est journaliste dans ces
matières des magistrats des policiers
des personnes des services de
renseignement au des hauts
fonctionnaires qui qualifie vraiment ces
jeunes encore une fois d'une très grande
radicalité d'une très grande spontanéité
et d'un très grand risque de passage à
l'acte en raison de leur culture en
raison du fait que visiblement il ya un
côté entre guillemets guerrier très
affichée donc abdul haq en europe il est
dans cette dans cette école si je puis
dire terroristes
parallèlement à ça c'est un individu qui
a posé des soucis quand il était quand
ils étaient plus jeunes d'entre eux
scolarisé seulement déscolarisés donc
des problèmes personnels
et quelqu'un qui est en même temps un
garçon de son temps si je puis dire
puisque il est totalement scotché aux
smartphones et aux réseaux sociaux et
qu'en fait il nourrit sa haine des
réseaux sociaux il cherche cherche ils
cherchent des cibles en réalité voilà
voilà qui est on the rough alors on
découvre en lisant votre papier on va
préciser qu'il a été abattu par la
police il a été abattu par la police
après les faits on découvre en lisant
votre papier ce matin qu'on peut
découvrir dans le print dans le figaro
dans les kiosques et puis également sur
lefigaro.fr papier écrit coécrit avec
christophe cornevin du service société
du figaro également qu'il s'agit
véritablement d'un engrenage infernal un
engrenage fatal qui a conduit à la fin
atroce de samuel pâtit c'est tout un un
tout une
succession de strates
absolument infernal qui qui font qu'on
en arrive à la décapitation d'un homme
et sa part d'un mensonge d'une
collégienne de 13 ans absolument sa part
de mensonge une collégienne et on ne
revient à l'univers du collège qui va
aboutir à l'horreur de l'univers du
terrorisme ce qui est intéressant dans
fin ce qui est
significatif dans cet attentat contre
dans cet assassinat de samuel pâtit
c'est que il y a quelques années on
aurait pu imaginer une organisation
terroriste comme l'état islamique ou
comme al qaida mandaté commandité un
attentat comme d'ailleurs ça a été le
cas contre charlie hebdo en janvier 2015
envoyez des terroristes et est décidé de
frapper sciemment un professeur voilà là
c'est un phénomène différent c'est à
dire que
il y à un islamiste
extrêmement radical qui cherchent des
cibles c'est de la can the rough il y a
des gens qui dénonce un comportement
jugé absolument inadmissible et
insultants envers le prophète sur les
réseaux sociaux avec donc au départ vous
l'avez dit le mensonge une collégienne
qui n'était pas présente un court puis
elle avait été expulsé expulsés de
l'établissement en question voilà et qui
en fait reprend au vol reprend au vol
probablement une une information qui
circulait dans le collège doux
malheureusement le 16 octobre au soir
ces collégiens qui vous disent on en
parlait entre nous donc qui sait si
c'était cette information et qui pour se
couvrir entre guillemets d'autres façons
peut-être
peut-être ma ligne peut-être aussi
naïve mais on peut être un mélange des
deux
confie cette information à son père qui
lui-même est un islamiste
aux tendances assez assez marqué et qui
lui dit voilà notre professeur à porter
atteinte au prophète a insulté le
prophète et là ça démarre le père fait
cette vidéo que beaucoup ont vu
extrêmement
violente en donnant le nom du professeur
le nom du collège
ensuite cette information est reprise
par un prédicateur islamiste
connu des services de renseignement
démarche auprès du collège
c'est un entretien avec la direction de
l'établissement également absolument
pour mettre en cause le professeur
samuel faty voilà on s'est remis en
question sa compréhension de la laïcité
même génie oui oui en fait on alors
l'attaqué naturellement assez subtil
c'est à dire qu'on ne se présente pas
devant le principal en disant qu' on en
veut à monsieur pâtit parce qu'il a
insulté le prophète a tout petit peu
plus subtil mais en réalité
ça revient à ça
samuel pâti comme on le sait lui-même
réalise que les choses commencent à
prendre une ampleur
c'est grave porte plainte et en marge de
sa vous avez donc ces réseaux sociaux
qui commence à bruisser de cette rumeur
qui sont à la fois des réseaux sociaux
qui sont constitués de gens qui
dénoncent
les gens qui insultent le prophète et
puis aussi des réseaux sociaux qui sont
constitués de gens qui eux pense à des
choses beaucoup plus radicale
s'appuyant sur les premiers et le drame
de conflans sainte honorine ces temps
quand effectivement en the rough qui
lui-même est sur beaucoup de réseaux
sociaux
obtient cette information et trouve sa
cible un an après on en est ou de
l'enquète je crois qu'elle n'est pas
achevée encore non elle n'est pas
achevée il ya encore des travaux
nécessaires d'après ce que je sais sur
notamment un certain nombre de messages
qui n'ont pas encore été totalement
élucidée ou décrypter donc il est
possible qu'ils aient d'ailleurs
d'autres interpellations à jour ou
l'autre
alors on en est à 15 personnes mises en
examen dont des mineurs puisque en fait
les si on prend le spectre des 15 mise
en examen c'est aussi intéressant parce
que précisément il y a les différents
éléments de ceux
de cette chaîne qui amène à l'horreur il
y a les proches d'abdul hack and the
rough acquis donc venez d'evreux en fait
avec sa famille et donc venait le jour
même d'evreux donc des proches des
relations de dan the rough qui l'ont
accompagné lorsqu'il a acheté le couteau
et larmes appelons avec laquelle il a
agi en ce qui concerne le couteau et
qu'on retrouvera près de son corps
lorsqu'il sera tué par les policiers il
faut préciser que les policiers ont fait
feu car en fait and the rough ignorer
les sommations visiblement souhaité en
fait les atteindre à leur tour donc si
vous voulez gasly à ses proches il ya le
père de famille et
de la jeune collégienne qui a menti le
père voilà le père de la jeune
collégienne le parent d'élève et
l'islamiste prédicateur qui l'a aidé qui
sont mises en examen pour complicité la
jeune collégienne pour dénonciation
calomnieuse
et puis il y a également
d'aider des jeunes collégiens puisqu'il
faut savoir que quand on sort of
arrivent au collège
il visiblement il aurait donné de
l'argent à des collégiens pour que les
collégiens lui désigne la cible faut
préciser que les collégiens
naturellement sont donc âgés de 13 à 15
ans placé sous contrôle judiciaire mais
la question de cet antre de cette
enquête dans son ensemble et pour
quasiment toutes les personnes indiqué
les proches d'anne zoroff
le parent d'élève et
son ami ou sa relation islamistes les
jeunes collégiens la question c'est que
savait-il du projet terroriste 29
était-il au courant jusqu'à quel point
il était au courant et jusqu'à jusqu'à
quel point était tyloo et jusqu'à quel
point est il au courant c'est
véritablement la question centrale
naturellement de cette enquête ces
derniers jours on a vu passer des
informations concernant une personne
mise en examen qui serait une jeune
femme de 33 ans et qui résidait dans le
sud de la france
priscilla m qui avait un surnom sur les
réseaux sociaux et qui aurait une
influence assez importante sur on the
rough est ce qu'on peut en dire un peu
plus sur cette cette femme alors elle
est elle même elle a un profil de
radicaliser à elle elle épouse d'une
personne qui a été condamné dans une
affaire terroriste elle a des relations
dans le milieu de l'islam radical
effectivement il semble qu'elle ait joué
un rôle enfin c'est du moins ce que
les enquêteurs pensent dans le fait de
transmettre and the rough qui faisait
partie de sa petite communauté sur les
réseaux sociaux transmettre donc la
vidéo est donc
signalé la sphère de conflans sainte
honorine and the rough après ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que dans cette affaire
il ya eu beaucoup d'interpellations
effectivement il est évident que les
enquêteurs ont
se sont intéressés et en détailler
l'ensemble des correspondants dans the
rough
parfois ça a donné quelque chose parfois
parfois il n'a pas été possible de
mettre en cause les personnes mais en
l'occurrence cette prescilla qui nie
farouchement
visiblement en tout cas aurait selon les
enquêteurs pu jouer un rôle de d'élément
déclencheur on le voit quinze personnes
mises en examen on est face à une
véritable chaîne criminel on peut
appeler ça comme ça avec aussi des
appuis quand on lit votre papier à
l'étranger alors
abdullah khan the rough était en contact
sur internet avec
des personnes séjournant actuellement en
zone syro-irakienne en l'occurrence en
syrie dans le nord de la syrie qui est
qui est encore un petit bastion de
l'islam radical
et effectivement notamment en contact
avec d'autres personnes russophone qui
aurait pu jouer effectivement un rôle de
mentor de conseiller voilà on est loin
du terroriste isolé ou du loup solitaire
comme ça aurait pu être évoqué au début
de la faire
que risquent les personnes impliquées
aujourd'hui les suspects qui ont été mis
en examen et en particulier les plus
jeunes qu'elle risque pèse sur eux d'un
bon début alors voilà dans ces 15
personnes pour le moment le l'éventail
aussi des peines d'abord encore une fois
l'instruction n'est pas terminée donc il
faudra voir ce que les magistrats
instructeurs
est ce que le parquet antiterroriste
décide à la fin de ces investigations
il est évident que entre la collégienne
qui est mise en examen pour non
dénonciation
vale pour dénonciation calomnieuse et
les personnes qui sont mises en examen
pour complicité d'assassinats on n'est
pas du tout dans le même registre de
bell voilà donc à mon avis il est encore
un peu trop tôt tout bêtement pour
répondre véritablement à votre question
puisque pour le moment encore une fois
l'enquète elle continue à essayer de
véritables en déterminer les
responsabilités des uns et des autres
enfin je pense qu'on aura à l'arrivée un
résultat assez assez contrasté
comment travaillent les enquêteurs sur
un dossier comme celui ci on leur montre
comment la chaîne il ya combien de
personnes qui travaillent sur cette
enquête on aimerait savoir parce que
c'est véritablement un événement qui a
choqué massivement les français les plus
jeunes comme comme nous
qu'est-ce qui est mis en place comme
dispositif de
d'enquêteurs de services de police des
services de renseignement pour
finalement
dérouler la pelote jusqu'au bout bon
alors bien évidemment vous avez fait une
priorité absolue vous avez à la fois la
police judiciaire la sous direction
antiterroriste qui est inquiète à
l'oeuvre vous avez la direction générale
de la sécurité intérieure qui est le
chef de chef de file de la de la lutte
anti terroriste en france qui a
également mobilisé ses équipes vous avez
également une coopération
internationale pour savoir si cet
individu avait des connexions à
l'étranger puisque encore une fois le
phénomène terroriste islamiste un
phénomène international avec souvent des
connexions ne serait ce qu'au des
connexions sur internet d'où les deux
individus dans la zone en syrie voilà
vous avez une mobilisation massive
pour pour d'une part savoir très vite si
cet individu à des complicités et
surtout des complices qui sont
susceptibles de passer à l'acte juste
après lui parce que naturellement que la
peur également dans ceux dans ce cas de
terrorisme islamiste c'est le multi
attentats et puis après c'est
naturellement quelque chose qui
mobilisent parce que parce que
l'attentât lui-même et la personnalité
de la victime justifie
ce fait est ce que ces policiers ces
enquêteurs qui travaillent sur sur cette
enquête la travailler sur d'autres
enquêtes
lié au terrorisme en parallèle non le
voile d'habitude ce qui se passe c'est
que on essaie quand même d'avoir des
équipes qui sont un peu dédié à une
enquête
après le problème des enquêteurs sur ces
affaires antiterroriste depuis
maintenant encore une fois six ans c'est
que les affaires se succèdent
l'attentât dans the rough encore une
fois est juste intervient juste quelques
jours avant l'attentât de la basilique
de nice un contre des catholiques
et comme on le sait le dernier attentat
terroriste islamiste remonte au avril
dernier à rambouillet où une policière
municipale a été a été tué ça suppose à
chaque fois naturellement la
mobilisation d'effectifs mais dans la
mesure du possible je veux dire les vous
avez toujours des enquêteurs qui sont
entre guillemets spécialistes d'un
dossier est ce que d'autres complices
pourraient être impliqués pourraient
être trouvées retrouver et être
impliqués dans cet assassinat de sa mère
pattie en plus des 15 personnes mises en
examen est ce qu'on était à la recherche
d'autres d'autres ramifications alors
c'est cette voie là je disais tout à
l'heure c'est possible puisque
visiblement la ramification de
du terroriste sur les réseaux sociaux
sont pas encore peut-être totalement
explorée il est toujours possible que de
nouveaux noms émergent il ya encore des
zones d'ombré point d'interrogation
ce qui est certain c'est que la
personnalité même du terroriste fait que
ça
l'étendue de ses de ses contacts et
aient été relativement large et ce qui
est important de souligner c'est que sa
radicalité était telle que sa famille
s'en était rendu compte
et que sa famille en fait laissé pieds
parce qu'effectivement vous en parlait
dans le papier la famille était au
courant des dd en tout cas des sites sur
lesquels en the rough se baladait et les
sites et en avait connu il avait
conscience de la dangerosité
en tout cas d exploration qu'il menait
sur les réseaux sociaux et les sites
internet qu'elle était conscient du fait
que l'or à leurs proches leur fils était
très radicalisé au point même qui
effectivement ils s'inquiétaient et
qu'ils espionnaient son téléphone
portable pour essayer de voir finalement
officiel et pourtant ils ne font pas de
signalement officiel et effectivement ça
pose l'une des questions
probablement centrale dans ce dans ce
terrorisme depuis maintenant un an et
demi à nous en sommes avec rambouillet
au 9e attentats perpétrés par des gens
qui ne sont pas véritablement connus des
services de renseignement comme des
comme des terroristes potentiels et à
partir de là ce qu'on appelle en jargon
le signalement donc le fait
effectivement de signaler aux autorités
la dérive d'un proche d'un ami peut-être
même d'un voisin c'est quelque chose qui
peut être absolument décisif en
l'occurrence ça ne s'est pas passé dans
le cas d'un de rohff et c'est également
d'ailleurs le cas
par exemple du terroriste de rambouillet
ça pose la question effectivement de
signalement par les proches comment il
aurait pu faire ce signalement comment
ça se passe quand on me signale
effectivement que on a un proche une
connaissance on soupçonne quelqu'un
d'avoir des agissements qui peuvent
aboutir à un danger extrême il ya un
élément tout simple c'est ce qu'on
appelle le numéro vert donc en fait un
numéro de téléphone qu'on peut appeler
où on est pris en charge par des par des
spécialistes ou ça peut se faire de
façon totalement discrète anonyme
d'ailleurs ça se passe il ya se passe
relativement régulièrement et un certain
nombre de personnes qui rentrent dans le
spectre dans les dents dans les radars
des services de renseignement parce
qu'ils sont signalés
ça peut être ça et puis sinon il peut y
avoir d'autres méthodes plus classiques
tout bêtement d'aller se rendre à la
brigade de gendarmerie ou comme il avait
vomi sur la police mais mais mais bon
voilà visiblement ça n'a pas ça n'a pas
été fait bon de toute façon dans le cas
d'un euro qui avait peut-être également
un autre élément qui aurait dû alerter
l'attention des autorités c'est son
activité encore une fois sur les réseaux
sociaux activités d'une telle radicalité
qu'elle avait précisément alors là pour
le coup
attiré et déclencher les signalements
d'internautes qui ne le connaissaient
pas ou même d'associations qui ne
connaissait pas non plus et qui
dénonçait ces
messages particulièrement agressif sur
les réseaux sociaux on l'a visiblement
il n'y a pas eu donc mettez pas et on
peut dire qu'ils n'étaient pas observé
il a été a été signalé mais il n'y a pas
eu de l'observation suffisante pour
anticiper c'est le passage à l'acte oui
mais en tuer le passage à l'acte
absolument c'est qu'il n'a pas été
considéré comme
comme comme entre guillemets
suffisamment dangereux alors ça souligne
aussi un autre phénomène qui est le
phénomène de la france de 2021 ou
d'ailleurs de l'europe de 2021 c'est que
la quantité de ces messages est
extrêmement importante il ya
malheureusement on sent sans tomber dans
la paranoïa et des dents mais il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de
radicaux qui se passé moi l'expression
qui se lâche sur internet et qui
nécessite des moyens pour essayer de les
détecter pour essayer de les comprendre
pour essayer de savoir si effectivement
il représente une dangerosité des moyens
très importants justement quels sont ils
ces moyens pour pour éviter il pour
empêcher un éventuel passage à l'acte on
a souvent entendu parler de ces fameux
algorithme qui repère les mots clés on
va dire mais on sait bien que
parfois on peut contourner justement ces
mots clés pour essayer de d'afficher une
colère ou humaine autrement que de façon
simpliste on va dire alors il ya il y a
une formule qui a été tellement répété
qu'elle qu'elle parfois qu'est laquelle
apparaît vide de sens
mais c'est la stricte réalité jeu tout
cas c'est ce que c'est ce que disent les
spécialistes et je le crois c'est que
y'a pas naturellement de risque zéro
c'est à dire que
c'est particulièrement compliqué
de traquer des gens qui ne sont plus
dans des organisations structurées qui
se contentent d'être inspirés par leur
entourage ou par leur fréquentation sur
internet c'est extrêmement complexe à
partir de là il y a des outils je pense
que les algorithmes
c'est un outil important le
renseignement de terrain
c'est également un outil important
la plateforme appel le renseignement de
terrain c'est-à-dire tout bêtement le
renseignement qui consiste à récupérer
sur place des éléments de 2,2 de la part
de de la part d'élus de la part
d'associations de la part de
d'honorables correspondants de la part
voilà c'est d'essayer dé c'est bien
d'essayer un petit peu de comprendre est
ce que ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya
des consignes massive nationale pour
inciter justement où payet d'élus ou
d'associations pour faire remonter dès
qu'il ya des événements des actions
menées ou des propos tenus de tout de
suite faire remonter et les informations
pour parvenir
détecter des individus potentiellement
dangereux oui il ya depuis 2014 un
certain nombre de plans contre la
radicalisation qui était qui ont été
mises en place avec notamment la
sensibilisation
l'incitation à signaler ces éléments je
les dis depuis donc le l'été 2010 9
depuis un premier attentat à lyon puis
l'attentât de la préfecture de police de
paris en octobre 2019 depuis ces
attentats qui sont perpétrés par des
individus qui sont moins directement
impliqué dans une mouvance terroriste
identifié il ya aussi vraiment ça aurait
été répétée par le ministre de
l'intérieur début octobre à l'occasion
de l'hommage qui a été rendu aux
policiers tués à la préfecture de police
de paris en octobre 2019 il ya un accent
qui est mise justement sur la détection
de ces signaux de radicalisation il ya
véritablement quelque chose qui mise en
place après est ce suffisant
on peut se poser la question est de
toute façon ce qui est certain c'est que
le signalement encore une fois il est
pas totale visiblement il ya encore des
failles il ya encore des choses qui ne
sont pas dites je parlais tout à l'heure
de l'activité de
du terroriste sur les réseaux sociaux la
plateforme pharos qui recueille ces
signalements si vous vous êtes si vous
surfez sur internet et que vous voyez
quelqu'un qui s'exprime de façon
extrêmement radical vous pouvez le
signaler et ensuite c'est quelque chose
qui est pris en charge qui est
décortiquée analysée
et les éléments les plus dangereux sont
pris en charge par les services de
renseignement voilà c'est qu'elle est
c'est une plateforme qui fonctionne 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
cette plateforme qui sont les assurances
il abat ce sont ce sont des policiers
des gens qui sont qui sont formés à la
fois la recueil du renseignement ce que
vous pouvez voir tout et n'importe quoi
naturellement et justement à une
première un premier écrémage bon il faut
savoir que la plate faro justement est
monté en puissance après l'attentât de
contre eux samuel paquet ce qui est bien
la preuve qu' il y avait il y avait
peut-être une lacune auparavant voilà
donc ça ça peut être également quelque
chose qui est mise en place maintenant
il faut savoir que l'adversaire il est
redoutable
qu'il est
relativement nombreux quand même vous
avez quand même officier ce qu'on
appelle le fsp rta le fichier de
signalisation des préventions de la
radicalisation terroristes vous avez
encore en fiche active environ dix mille
personnes qui sont qui sont fichés ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il y a dix mille
personnes qui sont prêts à passer à la
knu demain dans un collège ou ailleurs
mais ça veut dire que ce sont des camps
même les individus qui sont surveillés
ils sont surveillés 24 heures sur 24 non
ils sont pas surveillés 24 heures sur 24
parce que pour surveillé 24 heures sur
environ dix mille individus sa demande
des moyens totalement
en tout cas larges dépassant largement
ce qui est disponible aujourd'hui en
revanche
les plus dangereux ceux qui sont jugés
les plus dangereux sont effectivement
surveiller et de toute façon leur cas
sont régulièrement
réanalyser est réexaminée dans le cadre
de deux groupes d'évaluation
départementale radicalisation qui réunit
sous l'autorité des préfets les
principaux responsables des services de
renseignements des services de police et
de gendarmerie
de la justice voilà donc il ya
effectivement une veille relativement
permanente mais ça veut dire quand même
que depuis la guerre en syrie depuis le
djihad irak aux syriens depuis
l'émergence de l'état islamique le
phénomène du terrorisme islamiste devenu
un phénomène de masse qui qui nous pose
problème vous comprenez que quand vous
citez le chiffre de dix mille individus
fichés s en france même si tous ne sont
pas de potentiellement des individus qui
passerait à l'acte ça ne permet pas de
nous rassurer de rassurer les gens qui
nous écoutent qui qui savent qu'on
commémore aujourd'hui et demain
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit comment on
fait pour rassurer aujourd'hui face à
une menace qui est permanente vous citez
en particulier dans votre papier cosigné
avec christophe cornevin que l'influencé
majeure des réseaux sociaux en
particulier
donc il ya aussi des choses qui sont
absolument pas palpable qui nous dépasse
qui sont peu contrôlable et pourtant qui
agissent très largement sur les passages
à l'acte comme en ont fait aujourd'hui
et quels sont les moyens peut-être
qu'ils vont être mises en oeuvre à
l'avenir pour empêcher justement cette
influence qu en dix ans je je je vois
que à l'image nous avons donc
jean-michel blanquer
mise l'éducation nationale qui vient
d'arriver dans cet établissement
parisien du 16e arrondissement
l'occurrence le lycée jean de la
fontaine où on lieu comme dans les
établissements scolaires français
aujourd'hui à la demande juste une
demande de jean-michel blanquer des
commémorations qui sont une minute de
silence qu'on devrait entendre à midi et
puis les sens et les professeurs sont
censés passer au moins une heure ou
permettre pendant une heure de cours des
échanges des débats au sujet justement
de la laïcité la liberté d'expression je
sais pas si raphaël bekir en régie peut
nous mettre le son des images que l'on
que l'on obtient en ce moment en direct
et qu'on vous diffuse
là pourquoi
bruno descroix vendre
alors leçon n'étant pas très bon j'en
suis là je permets de vous relancer donc
sur cette question je vous posais sur
les moyens qui pourraient tenir 900
justement parvenir à
observer de façon plus prégnante
peut-être et empêcher des actes qui
serait mené au travers d'une influence
majeure des réseaux sociaux comme vous
le vous en parlez dans votre papier
aujourd'hui alors
160 sans être trop technique c'est pas
quelques 10000 fichiers sc quelques
10000 fichiers ou fsb rt bon peu importe
c'est juste voilà c'est pas c'est pas la
distinction est assez technique bon peu
importe
d'abord la première chose c'est
pour rassurer les gens
il faut déjà
dire la vérité
c'est cette cette menace elle est sans
cesse
dénoncée désigné mise en avant par les
autorités par les responsables
politiques
parlent et les responsables judiciaires
ou policiers quand ils s'expriment c'est
une réalité voilà je pense que c'est
important de savoir que le combat il
continue qu'il est loin d'être terminée
qu'il faudrait peut-être cesser de
penser que
après six mois sans attentat la page du
terrorisme est tournée je pense qu'il ya
derrière des gens qui ont un agenda qui
ont une volonté et qui frapperont dès
qu'ils peuvent frapper après il faut
naturellement plus de moyens il faut
plus de détection il faut plus de
finesse dans la détection il faut plus
de rigueur dans l'application
des lois
et des règlements voilà c'est ça c'est
ça la solution mais je pense qu'il faut
quand même qu'on soit conscient que la
lutte contre le terrorisme islamiste
elle est loin
malheureusement très loin d'être d'être
terminée parce que les fondamentaux
comme on dit sont toujours les mêmes
alors qu'on le voit en ce moment sur les
images que nous vous diffusons
le ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
s'est rendu donc ce matin et qui est en
ce moment dans cet établissement
scolaire ce lycée en paris paris 16ème
le lycée jean de la fontaine en ce
moment aux côtés de la directrice de
l'établissement on devrait pouvoir
assister à la minute de silence qui a
été demandé aux établissements scolaires
aux écoles aujourd'hui en mémoire de de
samuel pâtit donc ce professeur
assassiné décapité il ya un an le 16
octobre 2020 devant le collège dans
lequel il enseignait à conflans sainte
honorine alors je crois que jean michel
blanquer répond à quelques questions des
élèves en ce moment
les images qui nous sont fournies par
par l'allée par la fp je vous prie nous
excuser pour la qualité des images
un
[Musique]
procès lui les process du tout
produire avec pouvoir
voilà la professeur ou la directrice de
l'établissement qui est en train
d'expliquer au ministre de l'éducation
nationale les travaux qui vont être
menés pendant sept heures consacrées aux
commémorations de
samuel pâtit
jean-michel bancaire avait demandé aux
enseignants de consacrer une heure de
leur temps aujourd'hui en fin de journée
une heure de cours à des débats ou tout
autres travaux
qui leur semblerait utile et bien
en échange avec leurs élèves on écoute
un élève qui parle
m
sap a dit
e
et promouvoir
et promouvoir les valeurs de la
république puisque on disait on à faire
on a mené un travail vous pouvez en
parler un petit peu sur la démocratie
on a beaucoup parlé d'un démocratie
parce que c'est aussi à leur programme
citons casse de spécialités
histoire-géographie géopolitique
sciences politiques et on a travaillé
pendant là une partie de l'année sur la
démocratie et sur les nécessités voulait
peut-être en parler de ma démission mais
non c'est donc ce que j'aime c'est pour
ça ce sont des élèves qui sont dans
l'enseignement de spécialité et qui sont
donc engagés dans ce projet et qui sont
très engagés sur la démocratie est ce
que voulait en parler un petit peu sur
les problèmes qui se posent à la
démocratie sa fragilité total
d'ailleurs si le plus du terrorisme
c'est de faire peur ça rejoint la
question d'autres professeurs c'est quoi
la bonne réaction par rapport à quelque
chose qui cherchent à boucler cela
exactement
c'est ce qu'on fait là c'est ce qu'on
est en train de faire là est ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui et demain en
particulier rencontre vraiment qu'on n'a
pas peur deuxième en convient on est
unis ces deux choses qui sont
fondamentales puisque c'est précisément
ça que le terrorisme cherche à abattre
et cherchant à créer donc
parfois le terrorisme réussie certaines
choses parce que c'est vrai que le
kremlin terrain une société démocratique
une forte une société démocratique
républicaine doit montrer sa solidité
qui passe notamment par vous c'est à
dire par la jeunesse c'est à dire le
fait d'avoir les bonnes grilles de
lecture pour analyser ce qui arrive est
à voir l'attitude c'est à dire être unie
réunis ça n'interdit pas le débat au
contraire c'est précisément parce qu'on
est muni qu'on a un socle commun que sur
ce socle commun on peut avoir la liberté
d'expression et toutes les libertés en
général et puis montrer de la sérénité
alors dans ce genre de moment il ya
toujours des gens pour essayer qui n'est
pas de sérénité ce qui est très
important c'est sentir à la fois fort et
serein et
et on me fera sur un quand on a des
valeurs claires ça tombe bien notre pays
a des valeurs claires ces valeurs de la
règle c'est pas quelque chose de
subjectif c'est quelque chose qui permet
de bien vivre ensemble c'est ce que vous
êtes en train d'étudier à partir du cas
du terrorisme et ont tous répondre
n'importe quel autre porte d'entrée on
arriverait aux mêmes ou même chose parce
que c'est c'est la condition sinequanone
pour être dans un contrat social que
vous devrez étudier par ailleurs en
philosophie donc c'est très important il
ya eu une atteinte à la république et on
doit réagir de la manière adéquate est
le plus important dans tout ça c'est
vous et la jeunesse les enfants les
adolescents les jeunes pour préparer une
société qui justement soit solide face à
ce genre de choses il ya toujours eu ça
j'ai vu récemment les déposséder
posséder ou les démons de dostoïevski
pour autant d'être appuyé
la société russe a connu des choses
comme ça mais c'est ça fait partie des
défis qui sont posés à une société nous
nous sommes une démocratie
et on en veut aux valeurs démocratiques
la démocratie n'est pas la mode de
gouvernement le plus répandu forcément
c'est pas quelque chose de donner c'est
quelque chose pour lequel il faut se
savoir se battre parfois ce qui s'est
passé pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale par exemple de se battre pour
la démocratie et la ja ce genre d'
atteinte et on doit montrer que la
démocratie c'est pas quelque chose de
faibles c'est une chose de fort
et c'est fort pour permettre la
liberté n'est en aucun cas une faiblesse
au contraire
quand on dit liberté vous pensez vous
avez tout à leur liberté d'expression
pensez à quels autres libertés
oui à l'important liberté culte ça va
avec la laïcité justement parce que
c'est là aussi il est par exemple les
adversaires de la laïcité disent que ce
serait contre le culte mais pas du tout
c'est le contraire c'est parce qu'elle
réussit et qui à la neutralité et le
respect de toutes les religions c'est un
point extrêmement importante c'est été
fait pour respecter chacun dans ses
convictions en état physique on croit ou
qu'on croit pas et que soit la religion
ces messages il est très simple aussi il
est très très important
quelle autre liberté vous pensé
très fondamental aussi de la liberté
manifestation c'est vraiment le propre
de la démocratie et on a besoin de ça
sauf eu raison particulière pour comme
spécialité en plus parfois être une
exception mais justement doit très vite
pour qu'on retrouve une liberté
démocratique pour le mental est en
france on exerce beaucoup cellulaire
et ce cas de figure t ou êtes vous prêts
oui il verra ça va avec tout ça est lié
d'ailleurs tout ça fait système vous
allez bientôt pineau c'est pas loin de
la liberté qu une liberté d'exercer sa
conscience et c'est fondamental et nous
qui sommes nés dans une période de paix
de démocratie bref vous mais ces mêmes
red moi on est on le respire le la
liberté d'opinion comme l'oxygène trouve
ça normal et naturel et les heureusement
mais c'est bien mais il faut jamais
oublier que ça ça se défend si parfois
il faut savoir
la liberté de la presse
fondamental aussi personne de vanille et
ça
ça va avec évidemment c'est très voisin
d'ailleurs il ya liberté de conscience
et puis la liberté d'expression de la
conscience et donc la liberté de la
presse en fait partie vous voyez c'est
des cons des libertés il ya beaucoup
d'illustrations de la liberté c'est des
choses nous sont naturelles mais dont on
ne saurait être privé au même titre que
l'oxygène ou des choses dont on a un
besoin vital et c c'est le sens aussi de
tout ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
et si samuel pâte y ait
des morts quelque chose c'est bien pour
ça l'homme le meilleur hommage qu'on a
ambiancé faire ce qu'on fait penser à
ces sujets travailler à ce sujet les
approfondir et consolider la république
de façon à ce que nous sortirons plus
forts de sens je vous laisse profiter
je ne sais que dire
moi même un peu intimidé par cette
liberté de la presse
c'est important de
la dame sur le le projet vous avez en
lien avec les musées
ce projet est important de
déjà en anticipation de la création oui
les élèves réfléchissent beaucoup et
puis sont très touchés alors ça ils sont
un peu intimidés mais c'est un sujet qui
les mobilise beaucoup et qu'ils aient
tous beaucoup et puis c'était en lien
avec notre programme tout comme samuel
patinons je fais aussi dans le programme
c'était aussi un fonctionnaire de voir
le public et les au programme c'était la
démocratie et c'est vrai que on
travaille aussi sur
des démocraties qui
disparaissent vous rappelez et sur la
nécessité de créer et d'approfondir une
culture démocratique
vous rappelez
le pays donc on était en train de
traiter la part
parce que c'est un des points de passage
mais qui et à quel prix les attendait un
petit peu pourquoi là
rappelé de deux minutes ce qu'on a vu
en tout cas qu'il faut être vigilant
et que c'est vrai que le terrorisme
c'est la peur c'est la mise en scène
mais que nous on doit rester clair au
clair avec les avantages
de notre démocratie de nos libertés et
on expliquer tout à l'heure les élèves
expliqué tout à l'heure que c'est vrai
que on finit par oublier qu'on les a
première bonne santé
on finit par oublier qu'on est en bonne
santé on finit par oublier qu'on a ces
libertés démocratiques et il faut en
user et donc juste avant que vous
arriviez on est en train de parler de la
liberté ii pour le pluralisme de
critiquer des opinions et de la
particularité du droit français qui est
un droit laïc
et est ce que vous les ré expliquer un
petit peu ce que le l'aller les
conséquences de
le fep le droit et
laïque
par rapport à ce qu'on a dit sur les
religions
peu denses
donc
m
oui c'est important ce débat
démocratique on a étudié tocqueville
rappelé
j'espère que vous vous rappelez et que
disait tocqueville pourquoi quels
étaient les points de vigilance qui l'a
auquel il nous appelait
oui alors ça s'était plutôt c'était pas
top vivre mais c'était pierre
rosanvallon ils ont mené une réflexion
un peu approfondis pour essayer de voir
un petit peu quelles étaient les
fragilités de la démocratie et les
points de vigilance et que c'était des
libertés l'a expérimenté c'était pas de
seulement des libertés a énoncé
mecs étaient des libertés à faire vivre
et qu'une façon de faire vivre ces
libertés c'est effectivement
de lutter
contre ceux qui essayent de créer la
peur
d'alimenter les peurs et les patients
voilà bien on voit les ponts cas entrave
au travail sur l'histoire
par exemple il est aussi
évident je crois qu'on va devoir vous
voulez c'est
à l'auditorium
vous venez d'entendre on vient de voir
en direct l'intervention de jean-michel
blanquer au ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui était en direct depuis le
lycée jean de la fontaine dans le 16e
arrondissement de paris pour rendre
hommage à samuel pâtit il était demandé
aujourd'hui à l'ensemble des écoles et
des établissements france 2 consacré une
heure de cours à des exercices des
travaux en rapport avec la liberté
d'expression la liberté de la presse la
laïcité ainsi qu'une minute de silence
cette minute de silence sera
établi en tout cas préparé par les
établissements en fonction de ce qu'ils
sont décidés les uns les autres pour ce
qui concerne le lycée jean de la
fontaine on pensait avoir cette minute
de silence a visiblement elle n'aura pas
lieu maintenant donc notre émission
s'achève merci de nous avoir suivis en
direct sur figaro live merci beaucoup
aux gens qu'ils aulas pour tous vos
éclairages sur ce drame cet assassinat
de samuel pâtit dont on célèbre dont on
commémore aujourd'hui le premier
anniversaire ce sera donc demain 16
octobre 2021 ça fera un an que cet
enseignant de 47 ans a été assassiné par
un terroriste islamiste devant le
collège de conflans-sainte-honorine dans
les yvelines où il enseignait merci
encore de nous avoir suivi sur figaro
l'arrivée sur notre chaîne youtube à
très vite sur figaro life